[Musique]
sancerre village préféré des français
c'est pour bientôt en attendant le maire
de la commune vigneronne est très
content de voir le sancerrois mis en
avant nous avons une histoire comme
toutes les villes qui ont été
sélectionnés je les imagine ce qui nous
différencie bien évidemment c'est le vin
bien évidemment c'est le sancerre qui
est connu aujourd'hui à travers le monde
toute petite appellation est aujourd'hui
sur toutes les tables du monde vous
retrouvez le sancerre le 25 sept le vin
d'essence est roi à peine révélée la
petite cité perché sur son piton fait
partie des outsiders avec de vrais
atouts ça mérite d'être connu et puis je
pense que les gens y viennent pour pour
le vin dans tous les cas pour le
vignoble la loire il ya un beau
patrimoine
c'est un village riche en patrimoine
agricole industriel touristique
paysages et aussi c'est un beau village
j'aime bien et en plus elle va j'aime
bien le vin de r&d joli mur de belles
maisons une histoire riche un terroir
mondialement connu et comme toujours en
france du vin et du fromage car peu de
personnes le savent
l'autre appellation s'en sert c'est le
crottin de chavignol le sancerrois a
besoin de ses racines et et d'encenser
roya sancerre qui à la fois une ville
mais aussi une appellation
donc on a tout à gagner à faire redorer
le blason de toutes ces villes qui
finalement sont à proximité de tous les
français
le principe de l'émission est simple 14
villages représente les régions
françaises qui parmi eux un gagnant et
départagés par un vote du public
un vote possible jusqu'au 25 mars 18h
alors n'oubliez pas voter